welcome to a new series where i review
some games for all of you but not just
any games however as this series will be
focusing on the lesser known games
indie games games with a limited budget
or team or more generally games that
don't receive a lot of press
don't expect the elden rings or the far
cries of the world to be in here they'll
surely get their own videos but as for
this series we'll be focusing on games
that go under many players radars if
anything it'll make my uploads more
consistent too
the game hosting the pilot episode is
the ascent by neon giant let me know
your thoughts on the series down below
and let's get started so first up huge
thanks to the guys over at neon giant
for giving me a code early so i can get
this video out at a fashionable time
we'll first let's start with the
accessibility and platforms as well as
the basic rundown of the game
then we'll move on ahead into the
gameplay the story and the setting and
then to the performance
so for the rundown the ascent is an
isometric solo and co-op
shooter rpg on the unreal 4 engine
available on xbox and
pc for 26 26. it's also available on
xbox and pc game pass if you have those
subscriptions and by the time you're
watching this video the game is already
out so if this interests you at any
point in time you can buy and download
the game right away
sadly there is no playstation release as
i asked the developer some questions one
of which being platforms and they said
that for the moment they want to just
focus on xbox and pc
the ascent is a cyberpunk style setting
where you work for the ascent group in
this large arcology most people in the
world want to live here but
realize that it's more expensive than
they thought so they signed contracts to
essentially become slaves for the
corporation so they can live there
we are one of those slaves called
indents eventually we find out that the
company running the tower the ascent
group has gone bankrupt and chaos has
erupted so it's up to us to figure out
what happened
the ascent was made by a team of 12
called neon giant studio
googling their company name uncovers
that this is the studio's first game
that doesn't mean the devs are new to
the industry as the four founding
members have worked on games such as
bullet storm wolfenstein doom gears of
war and far cry 3.
now that the rundown is over we can get
to the gameplay and to get the obvious
out of the way like i said the game is
solo and co-op since i got the game
early i didn't find any co-op partners
to play with so all the game will be
from a solo player perspective but you
can play co-op online or
couch co-op if you have a buddy at your
house the ascent's unique mechanic or at
least unique to me was the ability to
take cover and alternate your firing
stance
running around and shooting is a very
effective and ideal way to kill enemies
but you can also crouch behind cover the
issue is that you can't shoot behind
cover because of the game's isometric
camera and combat mechanics
so by pressing the left trigger it aims
higher allowing you to shoot while in
cover or shoot someone at a slightly
higher elevation than you personally the
only game that i've played with this
camera angle that i can recall is diablo
and cover was never needed in a game
like that so adding both these elements
together was quite interesting it does
take some time getting used to but
eventually it will be second nature
going back and forth between cover and
running around when needed
just like any other rpg you have your
health stat a sort of magical ability in
this case called energy
as well as skill points and a variety of
armor guns and skills to choose from
and since this is an rpg game quests
have recommended levels to be at when
starting the quest and some areas are
level gated
going back to the basic shooting it's
actually quite fun
this game does require a bit of aim so
there is definitely a small learning
curve at the start but thankfully every
gun has infinite ammo so there's no need
to worry about it the game gives you the
option
of carrying two weapons of your choosing
as well as one tactical grenade two
augmentations that serve as your
abilities
two modules serving as more of passive
buffs and three
armor pieces your head torso and legs
each time you level up you gain three
skill points and you can put these into
any of the eight available skills some
of which can increase your health
critical hit rate or dodge cooldown you
can put 20 points into each skill
totaling a required 160 points or
53 levels to fully complete all the
skills now i haven't reached the max
rank but i can't imagine it being
anywhere close to level 50 as i feel
like that would ruin the fun of a build
if everyone is basically the same
character with almost maxed out stats
my hypothesis is that it's more closer
to 30 or 35.
like i said i haven't achieved this yet
so i'm not sure but that would seem more
acceptable there was also a bunch of
other nitty-gritty details like damage
types damage resistances as well as
crafting systems that are fairly
self-explanatory so i won't explain them
too much
but the damage types and resistances are
very similar to other games that you may
have played with these
some guns do better against other
enemies and some don't
same goes for the armor some have better
resistance to fire but
some are better at physical damage the
crafting is pretty basic too
since you just need components to rank
up the gun increasing its mark rank
after mark 5 it goes to the next
component and i assume it mark 10 it
will go to the very last rare
component of course to buy sell and
upgrade you need the vendors and at
least one area per level has a hub you
can do everything in from upgrading
selling to cashing in bounties for money
this leads me then to the map
the intention is that you slowly go up
in the floor so you start out at the
bottom floor in the deep stink then go
to the warrens and so on
to get to each level you must take an
elevator but you can then take a train
or eventually a taxi to certain places
on the map which protects that gameplay
loop from being plagued by a constant
walking and backtracking you can't take
a taxi from the warrens to the deep
stinks since they're on different levels
but you can take a taxi to any of the
named locations inside the warrens fast
traveling with the taxi costs about a
thousand credits a trip and while in the
early game it is quite expensive as you
get into the later levels it's quite
easy to acquire a thousand credits
but regardless one of the big reasons
it's so large is because there's tons of
loot to find
simply looking on the map will show all
the available loot chests you can
collect and there's lots to find in
these containing money
components and maybe some gear but this
is where it
loses me the game seems to pride itself
on exploration but not
too much exploration here's an example
on the warren's level which you get
access to around level 3. lots of
enemies are very low ranks as you would
expect
after a couple main missions you can do
a bunch of side missions naturally i did
the level 2 recommended quests first
since it was the easiest except numerous
problems arose because of this
one is that the elevator to get to the
location is locked as you need to
progress in the story to access it which
baffles me why i was given it now
instead of later but not even that also
10 feet away
are literal level 16 enemies who can
easily one shot me to reinforce my point
let's look at an actual main quest
i was told to go to the grinder district
in this quest which is behind this
turret
most players would see this path then
the alternate path to the right and take
that one first as it doesn't lead to the
main quest and there might be some extra
loot you can grab
the only problem is by simply going off
the beaten path for a little over 10
feet the enemies go from level 4 to
level 10.
this happened again on my way to the
grinder district where i arrived at a
town called gratitude on my way to the
main quest
i took a detour into gratitude and was
immediately killed by level 13
enemies it's just surprising how much of
a level jump these enemies have when
they're literally this close to the main
quest
anyone who wants to explore will be hit
with this unfortunate issue and it could
ruin the exploration for them
another issue i have is while i do
understand solo is always going to be
harder
than co-op sometimes i feel this game
really is geared towards co-op
only while cover is a necessity to
living in this game we think
enemies would at least adopt the same
strategy too and you'd be correct except
90 of them seem to not care they will
rush and flank you constantly making
cover practically useless when there's
at least 7 or 8 enemies at once on the
field
it makes it even worse when there's the
more tougher bullet spongy enemies in
the area
ultimately leading to your death either
way in this instance i was supposed to
hold out for 3 minutes and it's not too
terrible until the enemies start coming
out in waves and i'm overwhelmed
i can't run and gun because i'll get
shot and while i can dodge it's only for
so long since there's a cooldown my only
option is to take cover but i can't do
that either since i'm getting surrounded
i don't have an issue with enemies
rushing or flanking me i feel like the
game would be too easy if everyone
stayed behind cover but that's what i
mean when i say the game seems more
co-op oriented at times as even with
just a team of two it would make this
encounter much
easier to handle one small contributor
to this problem is the camera the camera
doesn't track the player merely move
with the player as if it tracked them
they'd be in the center for the entire
time
while this isn't terrible sometimes it's
atrocious where 70
of my screen is an unplayable area i
can't even get to so it makes no sense
to even show it especially during combat
this makes it easier for enemies to
ambush and surround me without me
knowing since the camera isn't showing
them
even if there were only a few enemies it
would still be nice to have the
character in the middle of my screen so
my aim is more accurate one thing that
is incredibly crucial is
upgrades usually in an rpg game there's
really no point to upgrading your weapon
since there's going to be a new one that
replaces it within the hour
the ascent doesn't really work like that
and it took me a few hours to understand
this
it seems to want you to actually focus
on the damage type and upgrade
here's an example eventually you'll
fight this spider boss and my main
source of damage was bullets
bullets are ineffective against robots
but by simply changing the shotgun i had
to a different energy shotgun and
upgrading it instead of saving the
components the fight was a cakewalk
so while i still think a good portion of
the areas is balanced around co-op
and not solo what really can save you on
occasion is upgrading and damage types
this pairs nicely with the plethora of
loot around the world giving you tons of
opportunities to craft
overall the gameplay is pretty solid it
gives the player lots of options to
create unique characters from skills to
weapons and armor
and the combat dynamic of alternating
from cover to run and gun works for a
majority
of the encounters if you're someone who
has a group of friends or is willing to
go into online co-op with randoms you're
gonna have a fun time
as for a completely solo player it's
possible but it might be tougher than
you think which could turn some players
off
all of this killing and upgrading and
walking all takes place in the arcology
so let's move on to the setting and talk
about the story along with it
simply put it's gorgeous it's crazy how
much detail
is actually in this game there's bags
people and objects everywhere
truly the highlight of this game it was
a clear progression in the environment
starting in the sewer tunnels of the
deep stink moving to the more livable
warrens then even the more extravagant
high street
even though each area per level is
somewhat the same which does have its
drawbacks from a level to level
comparison they are completely different
something i can't get over is the npc's
reaction to the combat
the combat takes place where npcs are
walking so they'll run at the sound of
gunfire but can also get caught up in
the fighting and can be
shot at the fact that whenever i want i
can just kill a group of npcs is quite
the interesting feeling
there isn't some law enforcement that'll
stop you either which kind of fits with
the theme
seeing as everyone at the bottom is
expendable so a few lives lost is no big
deal and it's even further reinforced by
the plethora of npcs that there are even
if all they do they're a stand and don't
talk it still adds to the overall
environment making it feel like what an
arcology would be
a very large but tight tower with
hundreds of thousands of people in one
area all crammed together
it feels alive and that's what a setting
should be for the story i'm going to
refrain from talking about the later
missions as i don't want to spoil the
later content but if you want to jump
into this completely spoiler free
skip to the time on screen to get to the
last section where we talk about
performance and my overall opinion the
story is actually what intrigued me in
the first place
i had to google what an arcology was as
i had never heard about this word before
this game
but after learning that and reading the
brief synopsis at the beginning it was
something that piqued my interest
and arcology is supposed to be a
self-sufficient tower you live
eat sleep and die in here you never need
to leave the building it has all your
basic necessities but also leisure
activities as well
basically take any city from its
population to its buildings and
businesses and cram it into a giant
skyscraper and that's what you get you
see what i mean you never have to leave
the tower that's why this plot is all
the more fascinating what would happen
if the tower you live in 24 7 was
suddenly not under anyone's command and
the leaders originally owning the tower
went bankrupt this affects everyone from
the top to the bottom
speaking to a character we meet later
named poon we discover that even our
paychecks are on standby so there's no
money given out to the workers this can
lead to poverty
and homelessness and when no one has an
answer to the problem riots can start
and seeing as most people are packing
heat in this tower many people could die
in here this alone
is great and the main reason i want to
continue playing during the story you'll
meet a wide variety of creatures all of
whom have their own personalities making
them seem like actual unique characters
not copy pasted versions of each other
sadly in its one criticism i understand
but still feel the need to bring up this
is only for the main campaign
any characters you meet in the main
story are professionally voiced with
unique dialogue separating them from
each other but the side missions don't
have this
all characters dialogue is garbled or
gibberish and either voiced by the same
person with different levels of audio
being raised to make it sound different
or only by a couple people in gt
operative you'll have access to select
gear and you'll be covered by a premium
y corp insurance policy
this is what i meant earlier i want to
criticize this but i feel like this was
due to having a small budget
as paying for professional or even
amateur voice actors is lots of money
especially when making an rpg which can
have hundreds of thousands of characters
that the player can speak to throughout
the game it didn't necessarily ruin my
experience with the game but after a
while it did start to bother me and i
just skipped the side mission dialogue
altogether
of course as stated before the main
missions characters and dialogue was
great but this however was lacking
overall the ascent's story is quite
unique with a premise i haven't seen in
other games that i've played which is
always a good start the main characters
are a joy to listen to even if the
vulgar humor does get annoying sometimes
i just can't say the same for the side
missions
the main quest is quite slow but
definitely does pick up later eventually
reeling you into the narrative
the side missions content is nice too
and gives the player a means of leveling
up with a small amount of story to flesh
out the world a bit
moving on to the last section is the
performance and bugs now this is usually
where most reviewers would list their pc
specs but seeing as i played on a series
x i don't need to do that but i do have
a few changes i would like to at least
be considered by the dev team since most
of these were quite bothersome
in terms of quality i didn't have any
frame issues at all nothing was frozen
or laggy the game ran
very smoothly there was one instance
where i was stuck in some geometry
thankfully the enemies did kill me
allowing me to reset but then i crashed
almost immediately after respawning this
is the one and only time i not only got
stuck in place but also crashed during
my playthrough so i didn't really let
this bother me the rest are changes that
either need to be added or removed
simply for quality of life
one huge issue was the ui text i play on
a series x connected to my tv from about
10 feet away
i checked this on a monitor and it's not
terrible but if your setup is anywhere
close to mine be very mindful of this
for the main hud the bottom right and
bottom left are very hard to read
especially the xp number it's so tiny i
can barely tell without looking at it
for a few seconds what the number is
the tech should be big enough to see
everything at a glance as there's no
time to squint at the screen when in
combat
another is the damage resistance and
damage type numbers on armor and weapons
especially when the number is red
as that coupled with the red background
is very painful to read
some of the tutorials are also culprits
of this too but especially the tactical
grenades i literally couldn't tell you
from where i was sitting what button i
was supposed to press i had to wing it
during combat to figure out how to use
them
speaking of tutorials every time i
logged back onto the game the game gave
me the same tutorials again
you can simply turn them off but i
didn't know when a new mechanic was
going to get implemented so i didn't
want to miss out on key information
it also didn't help that to close the
tutorial i had to hold b
which after the fifth time was pretty
tedious this then moves me to my next
problem
the menu i don't know why but when i go
through the menu there's this noise that
plays when i go from tab to tab
but if i go too quickly it overlaps and
plays a much louder sound
i have no idea why this sound is even
here if the sound was intended to play
either change the noise or just honestly
remove it but arguably the worst
offender and the most ear shattering
noise i had to deal with was when you're
indoors or near an indoor area i
understand the dev's idea behind this
since it's inside the sound has to have
a little bit of an echo as it would in
real life but they're amplified by a ton
and play
way longer than they need to
send you a present
this happened in just about every area
that was either indoors or near a door
that would lead to an indoor area
i personally don't know how to fix this
i would just assume either revert the
audio to match the outside and do away
with the attempted realism or
tune it down a bit besides this i do
have one change i would like added or at
least considered and that's rotating the
map
unless i miss something you can't rotate
the map at all it's incredibly painful
trying to see where i
am in relation to a quest or object but
can't tell since i can't rotate the
camera this would also benefit players
who are stuck
or lost thanks to the large amount of
twists and turns the map has
the ascent overall is a good game for 26
dollars you get the elements of an rpg
with a captivating plot as well as the
option to explore the arcology's
numerous levels to your heart's content
while there is some bugs and mechanics
that do bother me greatly i think the
positives of this game can outweigh the
negatives especially if you have game
pass
as what do you have to lose we have now
reached the end of the review
do let me know what you think about the
ascent as well as the new series down
below
as i'm always looking for feedback thank
you all for stopping by
if you're new make sure to subscribe for
more reviews like this as well as essays
on your favorite games
i highly recommend my recent upload in
which i explain why fallout 76
is one of my favorite games of 2021 as
always if you're a returning viewer i
thank you for supporting me by coming
back for another video
and with that take care everyone and
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you